foreign
it immediately starts burning for some
reason because I just did the back part
of my hand which is like why did that
burn well I don't know I put the cream
on this part I'm doing this and so I'm
like okay so that's your fault first
starting off yeah yeah that's definitely
my fault I can't hear him in mine
oh no I can't yeah yeah it's definitely
my fault for doing that right but what
is my fault is when you get something
right you go wash it off right so what I
did was I put hand sanitizer which
should be soaked on my hands wash my
hands rinse my hands and then I start
splashing my it starts burning more yeah
like why why would this possibly be
burning more I did not know that there
was hand sanitizer next to this thing
but you did no no because you live here
yeah but I don't I always use this soap
I didn't know there was hand sanitizer
which one's the soap I don't know I
always pick this up right no you don't
because you if you can't tell me which
one's the soap then you don't know which
one's the soap but I've never used hand
sanitizer at my own sink you've used
hand sanitizer and you thought it was no
no no because I would be able to tell
the difference because when you wash
your hands with hand sanitizer it
absolutely feels different than it does
with soap right so what I'm saying is
you used hand sanitizer you're like yeah
it's not really bubbling up like it
usually does and oh that's all right but
no I'm not gonna wash my hands again
I would know if there was hand sanitizer
next to the I've used hand sanitizer as
so before by mistake not at my house
and I have been like oh this must be
hand sanit this is bothering me so you
don't ever screw up you don't ever do no
I screw up all the time okay so but I've
just not screwed up in that situation
side by side so you've definitely done
it okay no I haven't I genuinely haven't
I'm gonna go get the two
[Music]
which one do you use I don't know the
soap one right but is it white or is it
black I don't even know what if you were
to ask yourself now I wouldn't even know
I wouldn't even know what color it is
now
there's a white one I know and that's
all I really know right I don't know if
I'll uh he'll show me just the white one
then guess what I I don't know don't
even ruin it because I'll look at it and
I'll say which one I use
uh you know I don't think anyone should
ever have hand sanitizer at the sink
well yeah well the the white one is this
is the soap
no this one's the soap
which one which one's the soap whatever
one says so oh yeah
yeah where does it say soap on here
there you go I said that where does it
say something
you just said oh that's what's the song
I said the white one's the song No and
then you said oh no that's one's the
same because he goes like this he he
falls no no no he held them both up
listen dude see he can't be wrong I
don't know what is this I don't use this
but you just said that was the soap
after he [ __ ] I go like this this is
the soap and he goes like this no he's
on both yeah because why would okay let
me can I just say this dude look if
these two are are on the sink
this is obviously the stuff that you
have to unscrew and put in this is just
a I would never ever you I I hand to God
I have never used this uh my sink okay
this should not be at the sink okay I
agree with you right do you know what
that could also be in the white bottle
dish correct but but even if but here's
the deal I have washed my hands with
this show and guess what that's okay it
is okay because you still do like that
but I don't want to wash my hands with
this soap well yeah well nobody I know
that's not dish soap right but you also
know that it's the the better of the
chance to make it so your hands are
clean is is right here because this
could be dish soap now if you're gonna
wash your face you got to look carefully
at what to do one time I I did a play
and this guy
ah this guy put this soap in the thing
and put it and he's like oh and I look
and it and he's like what is this and I
look I said Ajax and I was like you got
to go to the hospital yeah I've told
this on the podcast before but like you
could go to the hospital we were doing
the play grease and you put Ajax in his
eyes dude and it was so funny it felt so
bad for the guy yeah that's what it felt
like just now yeah well so you put hand
sanitizer in your eyes and that's how we
started sure okay so listen okay
welcome to the episode of
congratulations David is in tears
already because not even necessarily
because of the uh putting this in his
eyes which is the hand sanitizer that
Kristen puts next to the actual soap on
the
uh sink
and she shouldn't and I agree with that
and but you put it you wash your hand by
the way you put hand sanitizer on you
and you wash no bubbles you know not to
put it in your face right come on you
should have maybe thought what is going
on here no here's what I thought so I
put the hand sanitizer in there I start
doing this I'm like oh this is some sure
this is shitty soap it sure is because
it looks nice like a soap with that kind
of label in the brown bottle I'm like
man it sure it looks like shitty soap
right and so I I wash my hands I wash
them all off and I'm like God this year
is shitty and then I my hands are wet
but they're clean and I'm like I have a
little bit of water left and I do this
and I'm like ow ow that you knew right
away what it was though right uh not
really because I was like oh that's just
the water moving the lotion around so
you're not a good detective okay yeah
and then I was like this I've made a
terrible mistake okay so we all make
mistakes I've made mistakes I would
never make that mistake I would kill it
with that situation you just said you
didn't know which one it was I didn't
say that I said that's the soap okay and
then he goes like this and I go oh
that's the soap because I thought he was
trying to [ __ ] but he [ __ ] with me
so you guys were doing it no he was so
so you guys are queuing on and that's
fine and oh God and this is an episode
of congratulations now I I brought David
on here because I
I've I've had only guests I've had is my
my family really
um my brother Matt my dad bill and my
wife uh Kristen uh and everyone has been
blood I guess you could say your wife's
not blood but that's your family but
everyone has either been blood or family
but David Sullivan and David Sullivan is
one of my best friends in the whole
world I talk about him a lot on the
podcast sometimes I refer to him as
David Sullivan sometimes I talked about
as my fat friend and it's okay but that
so this is him why would you say I'm in
your family yay dude David Sullivan's
here no you have a lot of fat friends
I'm not one of them yeah so so David
Sullivan is uh one of my best friends in
the whole world came with me a few times
on the road yes if you you know elephant
in the room yes he is
I always say you're a great actor okay I
say you have a big head and you're fat
and you're a great actor and you talk
like this boy and I've never talked like
you yeah you do dude no no I may have
talked like that in junior high when I
didn't know how to speak hey boy that's
you that's my different Southern
impression and so but everybody's gonna
know you're dumb dumb because now
they're hearing me speak and they're
like why is he why why is he well he's
not fat he's really good looking yeah
he's a great actor we can just I mean
let me say you look good with a mustache
thank you so what is that texting in you
well it's a my well I just I had a beard
and then uh I have this this show coming
up and uh I think the guy has a mustache
show up doing the Mustang you think
you're pretty all right sure well in my
mind I'm like yeah that's good because
you make real choices as an actor right
yeah yeah and so and so that's part of
the that's like half the battle or what
uh yeah well I'm not a GI Joe but yeah
basically you I mean Life Is War okay
well no it's not
um but you do now what you do as an
actor you look at a role and you're like
okay how do I find my way into this role
right and I had a big beard and I I made
the tape and I was like I don't like it
and then they like me for the role and I
was like you know what the guy he's like
a sleaze anytime like sleazy or like
mustache mustache so it's kind of a
cheat but I do look good in it so are
you are you do you think that if you
were a an even better actor you could do
it without the Mustangs 100 but but you
so you're not you're saying so what I'm
saying is you you in a way it's like if
I were to put on a fat suit
or and and be an actor I'd have more
sympathy for me for my character because
I'm fat and people will be like oh [ __ ]
we got to feel bad for that guy if I was
really obese right but if I just show up
and I do the character like that they're
not gonna sympathy for me because my
shoulder's going for days right I'm veed
out and downwards
my shoulders go down my shoulders go out
like this right maybe I'm looking at a
difference and
so if somebody looks at me they're not
going to feel sympathy they're going to
be like how come he has it all right so
if I am a fat guy in a fat suit
I'm not as good of an actor because how
come yes I could have it all but if I
can make my body be
more sympathetic I wouldn't necessarily
need the fat suit so that's a good actor
I am and my goal is to ultimately play a
Korean person without using any makeup I
think I could do it
I think I could do it you're that good I
think I could do it I don't know if I'm
that good of an actor but I'm that good
at you know kind of
just gaslighting people into thinking
that I'm Korean that's well yeah you're
good at gaslighting people for sure but
you can't guess like saying you're
saying saying people convincing people
that you're fat even though you're not
that's gaslighting no I don't think you
can do that
I don't think I'm saying I'm that good
you're saying if anybody could it could
be you
which I don't I'm Korean so if I come up
to you and I say dude
if I come up to you and I say dude I'm
Korean you say what like and we didn't
know each other oh you were you were
born in Korea yeah and and I have and
I'm Korean I'm actually 100 Korean oh
okay so my mom and dad are Korean
maybe you should see my brother
you wouldn't believe me oh uh so you had
a different Dad no I had it okay oh
you're adopted you're you're adopted
parents adopted you and they lived there
from Korea I think I can make you
believe I was Korean I think I could
make most people believe I was Korean
that's a problem for everyone else what
is it I I know not for everyone else for
you for you to think that you can
convince somebody there you go
how'd you do that because because
because
I think that you have to have the
confidence in life sure you know yeah
um but that's delusional that's acting
it is acting oh yeah it's not healthy
okay
you think that Christian Bale isn't
actually thinking he's those guys when
he's being those guys 100 so me and
Christian Bale do that and yeah he's
been offered more opportunities on
Cinema to do that but when it comes to
real life if I need to pretend that I'm
Korean in a Starbucks or whatever I bet
I could get at least 30 of the people
believing I'm Korean if I wasn't
crystallia right they know they'd be
like oh you're the guy yeah but like if
it was just me and I walk in if I just
like slink into a [ __ ] you know Diner
and I'm just like yeah it's just me
people and and just me I need one seat
and you got you guys do have Korean food
right because I love food from my home
country people will be like really uh I
think I get 30 of people yeah yeah no I
I think you're right people will be like
oh he was born in Korea and his mom
without her career my mom and daughter
Korean by the way I'll get this white
fish and my mom and dad were born in
Korea
and immediately people were just like oh
yeah yeah that's you'll be like uh I
think a lot of people would be like he's
crazy but I think so we did agree to
disagree and that's fine so you're an
actor you've been in a bunch of stuff
right yeah um and I've been in a bunch
of stuff too so it's not a big deal no
not as high uh but we both
um
we both are you know you're an actor and
you're good and you're in primer and you
were inflate and you were in a movie
with Jessica Alba where you played a guy
what was that that whole movie with
sepia toned yeah yeah and what did you
and what what did you and I'd even see
it and I know it's CPS yeah well I
wanted an Oscar I want an Oscar you
didn't okay so let's talk about this so
you were in the movie Argo right yeah
which is kind of a rip because there was
already a movie Fargo well that has
nothing to do with I know but it's like
if I named uh if I had a if I had a
movie come out called ishin impossible
no Chris it's kind of the same no not
one person it's a little bit Argo
because they're like oh maybe it's just
like Fargo how about this sounds like
the Englishman who went up a hill but
came down a mountain that's like making
a movie like that because you they
already have them with Fargo and now
you're the movie right right right so
they're like oh this is this is Fargo
like part two this is like no it's just
it's obviously yeah no it has nothing
and so so if if I made a movie called
idler man right man and and the guy was
swinging from building to building but
also it was about you know journalists
yeah if you have people swinging from
building to building but this clearly
has nothing to do with it all right so
all right all right all right so they
should have called it something
differently like no that was the name of
the script the journalist that actually
that actually came out or the that story
it was based on a true story a little
bit and the script that the guy made was
called Argo why was it called Argo way
before uh the series Fargo came out but
Fargo the movie came out first Fargo the
movie did come out first Argo was based
on a true story about his face fake
screenplay where they went to go what
was the screenplay called it was called
Argo okay so you're let it be known and
this is you know gonna obviously make
huge press plays but you're saying that
Fargo ripped off Argo
no I'm not saying that Fargo is a town I
think in probably North Dakota so then
Argo ripped off the town so something
came first right but you're in that
movie and that movie was gangbusters
right now I didn't thank you no no no I
didn't say that I actually didn't even
just said it because I'm a bad friend
but I have seen all of your other stuff
except for that and the sepia movie with
uh Jessica so you're saying you've only
seen two of the things that I've done
I've seen primer and I've seen so many
episodes two but you were yeah maybe two
three maybe okay
um we made like 20 of those that's too
many episodes to make oh really honestly
yeah huh if you were really we've
watched 20 episodes of NCIS I know so
what you're saying doesn't make a lot of
what you're saying NCIS is a good show
or a bad show it's a bad show there you
go you love it but you love it so
because it's bad right right so there we
go so but my Show's not you're welcome
for only watching your show three
episodes because it's a good show dude I
don't watch good shows so there we go I
got into that one now
now so you're in the show flaked you're
in the movie primer you're in the movie
um uh uh Argo which you it won an Oscar
for what best picture and and uh I think
F like may have won for director okay so
I thought he went for director no maybe
not no no he didn't he didn't actually
it was it was uh someone else and I
thought remember that year I was like
that's [ __ ] you could win best
picture and not Best Director yeah I
don't ever understand how a movie can
win best picture but not best around
yeah do you agree yeah that's tricky I
mean yeah it's weird because the
director is in charge of everything the
whole thing yeah I I well I I think the
story itself was so good and it was yeah
it was produced so well but I do think
yeah I do maybe it wasn't edgy enough
like maybe it wasn't like something in
there where people were like oh it's
like but nobody you haven't watched it
so you don't know but no anybody who's
watched it will say yeah that's a good
movie right like that's a really good
movie that's probably why you don't
watch it because it's good right
probably but it is it is very strange
when when yeah yeah when it wins for
best picture so you need to have
basically political stuff there too I'm
sure which is why you need to be aligned
with medical ideology of the academy and
to be winning everything and then also
you have to have some sort of like edgy
but it was edgy was kind of edgy yeah
yeah but what one who won the Best
Director with score City what was it
that year I know it was excuse me never
won right uh what won that year for Argo
uh rip off of Fargo
um but but was there a bet so you won
bet so it won best picture yeah and
you're counting that as an Oscar win for
you well I also won a sag award it won
sag Award for Best cast Okay so that's
so you're saying I have the plaque they
gave it to you yeah yeah okay well I
they actually sent they sent me two that
were wrong one of them was said Larry
Sullivan they said that in the mail and
I'm like hey I think you guys made a
mistake Larry Larry the worst because
you know what because you had the
mustache
and then I let them know that and then
six weeks go by I get the thing in the
mail and then they they misspelled they
didn't even finish my last name it just
says David sulliv s-u-l-o-i-v and I'm
like oh
so I actually have three certificates
dude I absolutely yeah yeah I have three
certificates Larry Sullivan David
Sullivan okay so you basically
um but yeah I won uh I won a sag award
for uh that's ensemble cast and then I I
we right if you watch the if you watch
the speech that Ben Affleck gives when
we won best picture he thanks me does he
yeah he thinks he's like yeah you know I
don't think he does he does if you watch
it you'll see it's uh does he say thank
you David Sullivan Larry we couldn't
have done it without you dude now you
look like you sell jacuzzis so what's
the deal you do you really look like you
sell jacuzzis just the way you're
dressed and the way your facial hair is
you obviously are jacuzzi salesman so
how did you miss that uh calling to be
an actor do you do you draw from like
how often do you think about jacuzzis
basically how often do you think about
the price of jacuzzi not once not once
have I ever thought about the price of
jacuzzis I've played at Winnebago sales
there we go dude that's Typecast man
that's Typecast because they know no
dude that movie they were looking for a
50 year old and I did this movie 10
years ago so I was in my I was barely in
my 30s okay they were looking for a 50
year old overweight maybe I have the
energy of a fat man there we go we've
figured it out yeah but I don't look
like that so you look great for your age
I'm gonna tell you that yeah you know
you you you
still look like a Winnebago salesman and
a Jacuzzi salesman uh I could get you
look like a guy that could go like this
I could get it for way cheaper than that
for you and if you've unmatched that
price that's you say that a lot oh yeah
yeah so you can beat that your destiny
was probably to be some sort of salesman
probably I feel like you would be a
great salesman because here's an
annoying [ __ ] thing about David
Sullivan yeah okay and one of the
reasons why I love him but then I also
hate them because here's the thing I
always say this on my podcast if you
don't hate your friends your friends
ain't [ __ ] okay so here's what I dislike
about you you will say hey man [ __ ]
uh uh Billy's gonna be at the park we're
gonna go to the park 4 30 and I go
really and then you tell Billy hey Chris
gonna be at the park at 4 30 and then we
get to the park and we realize that we
both said yes without you even asking
the other person first right so you
don't you you will do what agents do you
will say hey
um Billy's going to the park before even
asking Billy and you'll tell Billy Chris
is going to the park this way you know
there's a better [ __ ] reason for me
to go to the party no no no no no I'll
I'll uh I'll be like hey you want to go
to the part today it's like yeah what
time you want to go and I'll be like uh
yeah four o'clock and I'll I'll I'll
plan on I wouldn't tell you hey go to
the park and maybe my friend's gonna no
you wouldn't you'd say he's he's showing
up and then yeah I would only say it if
he said he was going to come I don't
know you got to come up with a better
example that's that's what you're what
I'm saying is it's really good for a
sale what I will do is I ain't justify
the means if we're all there having fun
at the park or all they're having fun at
the park it doesn't really matter if you
skirt yeah but no no no you're a very
honest person though I will give you
that much no but I will make sure that
things are lined up a certain way now if
they don't if we get there and they're
not lined up a certain way that's no
longer my fault like if Billy says yeah
I'll be there at 4 30 we get there 4 30
he's not there is that my fault no
that's that's not your fault but that's
not what I'm talking about that is what
you're talking about that's exactly what
you just said so you're talking about
something you're not talking about so
you okay so you won't say to somebody
okay say you send a text to Jason yeah
we're going to the park at 4 30.
he's going to say who's we that's it
that's all you send to Jason okay you
won't tell me right hey
Jason and I were going to meet at the
park for at 4 30.
well I don't understand why that's all
you do is say Jason
Chris and I are going to be at Park at 4
30. You uh-huh and then to me hey Chris
Jason and I are going to the park at 4
30.
yeah you would do that yeah
Jason didn't confirm yet that he's going
to the park for 4 30. you just told him
that you're going to the park at 4 30.
see you would do it dude he's an agent
isn't it dude yes I'm a lawyer yeah but
if I say we're going to the park at 4 30
and he says okay that's different but
you at your heart in your heart of
hearts inside your heart there's a
smaller heart that's stronger and the
bigger heart can beat because of how
strong the smaller heart is and in that
small heart you sell jacuzzis and that
is what you need for that you need that
heart that beats inside the bigger heart
to make you who you are and that is your
destiny and that is a Winnebago slash
jacuzzis
no I'm gonna disagree I I you did kind
of catch me in that but that is because
I believe in my friends
if I say if I say hey uh uh uh Brent uh
I'll see you at the park at 4 30. I know
Brent's not gonna show up till six I I
know that like that's so I wouldn't say
hey I'm meeting brenta Park so I I know
because of my friend chance who I can
count on who I can't oh God so it all
sounds you'd like to think are bad about
me they're actually really good about it
there we go you just have a weird eye
you have a weird way of processing
things all right so I you know nailed
you no you didn't tell me because I
don't agree with that you agree you
don't have to well I didn't agree with
it and you nailed me and I said you know
you great you agreed with what I was
saying you go yeah I would do that and I
go yes and you said I'm this way and I
said I don't agree with that so I'm
winning in the conversation
but but here's the thing dude we've
known each other for
uh 20 years close that's crazy bro yeah
I don't want to know anybody for that
that I think this might be the last
the last of hanging knowing someone for
too long is just it's going to be sad
later because one one of us is going to
die first
what is wrong with you don't you ever
think about that no
who do you think will die first
you
for sure why do you say that you're
reckless
um
I mean I'm dangerous but like you're
reckless no I think though
well like not really like if if who's
gonna go hang gliding out of the two of
us oh yeah well but you don't do
anything
so let's talk about you just make bad
decisions but let's talk about two
things okay
you I make good decisions and I know
everything's safe go ahead okay yeah you
are uh somebody that I've known for 20
years and also
you know I don't like to do too many
things right you like to do
everything right
so my question is
what are you running from
right
um what if I say hey I'm going to the
max you don't make sense let's go yeah
okay so
that doesn't make sense and it does so
and I'll and let me just break it down
for you
let's go to the Mac Store you say all
right cool yeah let's go [ __ ] it right
if I say I don't talk like that hey boy
let's go man do they got I can so I
could spit my backy in it I've never had
a spatoon so tobacco
um where your boots at you at the Mac
Store you guys sell boots are they
Bluetooth
um you got you got shirts with pockets
with the white buttons on it dude you
love shirts with pockets with white
buttons on it dude it's the most Texan
[ __ ] of all time all right
two two one here one here
yeah I love it so so you wear that so
and so now you are
you do it you and if I say so let's go
episode you said let's go if I say let's
go get a lunch you say let's go if I say
let's go hike you say let's go yeah if I
say let's go to Vegas this weekend you
go like this
yeah let's go yeah okay so what are you
running from I'm not running from it it
makes sense though because why are you
always doing all of this [ __ ]
Let me refresh the question is there
anything you're running from you've
already asked me that and I said no is
there anything you're running from no
okay I I the walls are up I grew up in a
small town but in that small town I was
surrounded because it was small there
was a lot of people in my little area
and in girl I have an older brother
older sister but I also had six exchange
students over the course of like 12
years so there was always people a lot
of people in my house yeah so I like
being around people that I like and the
rest of the time guess what I'm with me
and I like me but I also like being
around people that I like and believe it
or not I like you I've liked you for a
long time and so I I like I like being
around you and also it feels it also
feels good for me to help people and
you're one of my friends who needs a lot
more help than most people so I happen
to be around you a lot because you need
a lot of help
um and that makes me feel good so you're
using me no
it makes you feel good I need help and
you're using me I'm helping you if you
look at it under a different list why do
you look at everything so negative
because I'm Different dude you know how
they say dude I'm built different thing
I'm different yeah I'm different dude
and that's honestly
thank you're welcome dude and here's the
thing thank my parents too if if um you
know uh I was raised in a different uh
city or town I could have possibly been
a warlord but because I came from La
Canada and my parents were my parents
I'm just a very specific comedian
instead of that the problem is you
actually think that that's true
dude honestly
I I would like I I I I I would like to
say you're welcome for me not being
alone the Lord said thank you I know but
I'm saying it mostly to the people who
listen to congratulations but I on the
other hand going to back going back to
what you might be running from and maybe
you're not running from anything is what
you're saying I'm saying you know
everybody's running from something but
for me
I don't do things because I don't want
to get outside of my comfort zone and I
am I am scared of certain things and I
don't want to try new things because uh
I live in my head and in my own world
that's not an answer
that's the you don't have your
headphones on but that's the Jeremy
Renner [ __ ] that went oh my God you know
how sometimes it goes you have these
things queued up well I thought they
were done in post anyway but that's not
an answer that so why don't you do
things
that you know might be enjoyable you
said you're scared what are you scared
of having a good time
I don't know
like when we were in Boston I'm gonna
turn the TV off in the other room yeah
and I was like hey dude we're in Boston
let's like go let's walk the Paul Revere
Trail like let's see where Paul Revere
rode and like you know warned ever the
bridge and you were like no no we don't
do that and I'm like what does that mean
we don't do that he's like we got coffee
we chill at the hotel we eat we do the
show I'm like yeah but but you just said
second right there sounds [ __ ]
banging dude
you me being all like this on some
cobblestone
but we're not just gonna like see like
we're gonna experience like what what
the history we're gonna like be in the
place that like Changed History like you
don't know how that would make you feel
because you haven't let yourself try it
history already happened dude we got to
deal with it I know but to be in touch
with that that's how we learn we love we
learn from our past
so there's probably something that
you're dealing with and like not
necessarily the past but like you don't
want to put yourself outside of your
comfort zone because you may learn
something about yourself that you may
not like and that you may have to do
work to fix it
and doing work on yourself is scary
echoing I get yours right here
his name is Paul Revere it's a horror
movie
fire for my childhood anyway
canned
crystallia in
crystalia and Jeremy Renner
dude it's like that [ __ ] hell Jordan
Peele does his like does oh you can put
the microphones on
but dude dude it's like what Jordan
Peele does the old the slow songs for
the horror movie and [ __ ] just I gotcha
I got what's right here his name is
Paul Revere dude that sounds dope put it
on yeah hell yeah dude listen listen
this is like Jordan peel movie the
horror movie It's called
can you hear it yeah can you hear this
can you hear this can you hear that oh
yeah yeah dude
I got you I got yours right here his
name is Paul Revere right are you off me
yeah well yeah because I have to keep
hitting it
anyway
but wait what and so with that it's a
zoom and then your face gets me off
figuring out no it goes in my eyeball
and in my eye there's fire all right and
it's my it's me as a kid and [ __ ]
right right demon crawls inside my mouth
all that kind of [ __ ] so let yourself
experience things that's all I'm saying
or live in my head dude
foreign
yo it's so dope to live in your head I
do have problems
um and I would like to confront some of
my problems and I have confronted a lot
of my problems but it is actually
[ __ ] hard a yes dude it's so hard you
know what I tell you man I hate being
alone I hate being alone and it's very
weird and I don't mean by the way with
my phone or
anything I mean alone like alone alone
yeah
I I don't like that do you have you
asked yourself why you don't like being
alone
because we are not going to get into the
territory so that go ahead so that
answers your question like you don't
want to look inward to see what it is
that you need to work on because it's
scary and it's going to require work you
you you have you have had a lot of
things go your way yes you're a hard
worker but like you your life has been
pretty good this is okay like you you
have a family who loves you you you're
you're they support you like you've
always felt their love and in having
that love and that support system you
pursued a career that by all means you
should not succeed in but the fact that
you had that support and the fact that
you were good at it and you worked hard
at it and you did have something special
I wouldn't say that you could be a
warlord but thank God that there are
still you do still have issues that you
need to work on and because your level
of success has you have been rewarded
for your behavior you haven't spent time
to think about the things that really
trouble you and I think I think you're
on your way in doing that tiles done
man that's so shitty what you just did
file done dude
we did you hear anything I said I did or
were you thinking about what what joke
can I make well I was thinking that too
yes okay now I
don't you know it's like
you know okay you know I'm saying
you're not saying anything yeah but so I
you can't say you know what I'm saying
if you're not saying anything rappers do
it all the time yeah
um
so sit with yourself I do do that and I
hate it yes what you hate it because
you're realizing that there are things
that you have to work on and and you
only want to work on three things you
want to work on coffee and comedy and
and chilling but like that's not you've
created a world where that's okay
because I mean we're literally doing
this in your house but like there's a
world out there and you've got to know
how to like experience yourself in that
world and the only way you're gonna do
that is by practicing it by doing things
outside your comfort zone I see what
you're saying so like I'm too late to
learn what I'm too insular I need to be
like doing stuff like like hot air
balloon rides and [ __ ] sure basically
you're saying if I do enough hot air
balloon rides I'll I'll if I did a a
hot air balloon ride and then also some
like uh some like yoga and then also a
trek yeah you think that out Trek would
make somebody a better person yes you do
uh but but I would start with a walk
around the block
you live in a beautiful neighborhood I
do Sprints that's not what I said okay I
said I'll walk around the block all
right like just go out hey I'm gonna go
for a walk for a half hour and come back
and I you'll probably come back in tears
because you would have used that time to
do something that matters and you know
what that's okay that's growth because
you're you're checking into something
that you don't allow yourself room to
check into because you think oh there's
a lot of darkness in there oh there's a
lot of problems in there yeah but how do
you fix those problems how do you how do
you shine a light on that Darkness right
by asking yourself those questions I
think that would be awesome and I I yeah
I don't know I think you'll you'll be a
lot happier and you'll allow yourself to
do cooler things
um so hey you're welcome no honestly
you're a bad therapist how uh I'm not a
therapist but how how is anything
how was anything I said bad no it wasn't
bad it was said you're a bad therapist
no no I'm just saying I'm but that is
what you said I know but I'm just saying
that you'd be a bad therapist we know
that you don't have any training but
um if I had training yeah I would be a
great therapist yeah just like you if
you practice at anything long enough you
get good at it like anything right if
you keep doing it obviously well not I
mean not not necessarily like I could
try as hard as I wanted to be a [ __ ]
alignment on the NFL but I can't I
couldn't do that right if you practice
hard enough obviously you wouldn't have
the same physical capabilities but you
could have been a good lineman in high
school
what are you 5 10 5 11. I'm 6'2 man were
you six two in high school oh uh uh I
don't know I don't remember yeah you're
probably like five you're a short guy
you kind of have short guy syndrome
um so you were probably like five six
five seven and if you worked out hard
enough then you could have done it I'm
veed out my [ __ ] goes you know from my
ear to the end of my shoulder it's oh
it's we it's a weird amount of space let
me see
huh it's a weird amount of space right
like if okay I'll put it this way you're
saying you have short legs put it this
way
if a pirate was on top of your head and
another person that the pirate wanted to
walk the plank and he said walk the
plank ready and he had to walk off your
shoulders the guy would be like no I'm
gonna die so soon if they did it to me
on my head they'd be like phew at least
I have some time okay that that's all
I'm saying there's a lot of real estate
between my ear and the end of my
shoulder
yeah but it's specific yeah that's what
I'm saying so but you don't like when I
live in my head oh I should go out and
do hot air balloon rides in a trek dude
I got [ __ ] in my head that I live here
and this is why I live here and you're
laughing having a good time you're
welcome I sacrifice myself for others
dude we understand we understand
convince yourself of things that aren't
true though [ __ ] agent [ __ ] that's
dangerous though like yeah you're inside
your head the majority of the time
you're you you're you you're who you
have to be with but there's a world out
there man so when you go out there and
you are doing something you've never
done before yeah you feel good because
of what not always sometimes it's like
oh this sucks but like a lot of times
it's like oh I can I can see what's cool
about this or like they're very
optimistic you're an optimistic person I
am I I I try to live more positively
than I I you used to I try to be part
positive and I try to look at the things
in a different way yeah you know because
I think that you have to grow in life
and I know we're joking around about how
I [ __ ] I I [ __ ] don't like
everything but that's obviously another
things I like no there's things I like
and like I wanna I wanna be more often
to you know to what what are they right
now well uh for instance I mean I love
you I love being a dad I love having a
family and [ __ ] like that but you think
that that doesn't count because I'm just
here anyway but you know you're talking
about things to get out there and learn
about myself like you want me to pick up
an abacus and start learning how to do
it but it did you know and it's like I
just want you to have a hobby I do need
a hobby yeah I've tried certain things
you know but if it's not with my son or
my family like like I went to Color Me
Mine with Calvin and we all painted like
like mugs and [ __ ] I had a blast dude if
I went to do that alone dude
I got yours right here
his name is
you know what I mean no
I think you do
I don't know what all this stuff is so
in movies when songs slow down and they
get lower yes it's ominous yes all right
yeah so people could be having a good
time and then all of a sudden a slow uh
ominous song happens and it zooms into
someone's eyeball and you see into their
soul and so if they're doing this song
from Guys and Dolls that nicely nicely
sings
[Laughter]
and it's going uh because usually the
song's like I got your whole time here
his name is
the weather is clear I can do can do
right but if you slow it down and make
it more ominous I got yours
[Applause]
Blair weathers clear and you go inside
my soul and you see me as a little child
on fire my former self and my mom is in
the back but we just see a shadowy
figure but I know who it is
okay
you know there's some deeper [ __ ] going
on yeah all right yeah yeah
everything that isn't nurturing can be
trauma and
can do starring crystalia and Michael
Chiklis and so and a woman who you can't
tell what her race is
and it comes out on [ __ ] Hulu
tell me that doesn't make sense well I
just didn't understand all the zooms and
all the the the things that you were
doing that's because you're too busy
[ __ ] hiking dude and doing traps oh
God and learning how to play Pickleball
no me I sit
how did I distract myself with friends
and [ __ ] and my son and I'm in my head
dude but whatever dude speaking ahead we
got [ __ ] life rips bucket hats dude
chrisley.com you know what I will be in
Sugarland Texas I will be in uh San
Antonio Texas I will be in San Diego you
go to see crystalia.com you go to all
the tours you go to go New York New York
I'm gonna go to Chicago I'm gonna go to
Seattle I'm gonna go to Portland I got a
bunch of different places that I'm going
to I want to be on tour chrisley.com and
uh and that's what's up why don't you
take it out and then put it under the
desk and then you can put it under there
this way I'll go under it
um but yeah that's where I'm good that's
we're gonna be almost throw up in my
mouth but that's where I'm gonna be and
um
and uh so if you want to come see me on
tour go to kristalia.com and if you want
that Chrisley emergency go to
chrysler.com and appreciate you hey guys
that's it for the episode for YouTube if
you want to catch the uncut the
uncensored the raw the unedited version
all you got to do is go over go on over
to our patreon that's patreon.com
crystalia and you will get the rest of
this episode and you will also get the
extra episodes
um that are one one we do one a month
for only patreon people so and you can
get that for just six dollars a month so
that's patreon.com crystalia thanks a
lot
[Music]
thank you
[Music]